at the end of last year 2020 i published
a series of stories in medium called the
transformation
it tells the largely positive story
of 2020 to 2050 from the perspective of
someone
in 2100 but it's more than a story
it's the best case of what i think is
largely happening and could possibly
happen in the next 30 years
i think we're on the verge of another
technology and economic boom that could
dwarf the one we just went through
through the last 30 years
it may be not just a long boom a second
long boom two
but a societal transformation and in
fact we could be making great progress
on all four
of the era's challenges that i mentioned
beginning including like
climate change by 2100 if we have
solved climate change and when i say
solved i mean mitigated the worst
excesses and it's successfully adapted
to kind of live in a thriving way
if we get through that we actually will
probably have gone through something
that's closer to a civilizational change
the era from 1980 to 2100 that period
may be understood as something
comparable to the enlightenment
and in many ways it might supersede it
in every way that's ultimately why i
call
this whole project the transformation to
make that direct parallel
so in this talk i'm going to make the
best case to convince you
that we're heading into a bigger long
boom than the one we've even been
through and that we're in the early
stages of
civilizational change